surrounded by israeli security forces
even though clearly identified as a
journalist
they just came from everywhere i don't
know why
and they kicked me to the wall and
what is your idea i told him you know me
and you know that we are
coming and going in many times
overpowered and cornered budari was
handcuffed and dragged away
they brought me to the investigation a
video about
just more less than six seconds
my hand is like this to the soul to the
to that soldier
uh inside and then they kicked me inside
the car in a very bad way
handcuffs they were just making like
this
and like this getting them tighter
tighter inside the car and they were
kicking me from everywhere
buddha and her team were covering a
peaceful demonstration
organized in solidarity with the
families on the threat
of forceful eviction in sheikh zarah in
occupied east jerusalem
she had done several live reports
already when the security forces started
pushing away journalists
she has been accredited with israel's
government press office for many years
she was held and interrogated at the
police station
where budari says she was treated like a
criminal
after seven or eight hours i don't know
how much time because they took
from me everything they refused to take
the cuffs from me
they said either arrested or
15 days away from because of the video
evidence
yes yes we will go to the court because
it's our
because it was a message for all every
all the jewelers
we kicked al jazeera we put it uh we put
now al jazeera in our hand
so everybody will be afraid and nobody
will cover
no we will cover everything jvara is one
of the most experienced journalists
covering events in israel and the
palestinian territory
her arrest is being seen as an effort to
intimidate journalists
and has drowned global condemnation this
is a clear violation of press freedom
because this journalist was clearly
recognizable as she was wearing a press
vest
and there is a clear will from the
israeli authorities to prevent
journalists
from doing their job and from reporting
on the ground
throughout her ordeal jivara was denied
the request to remove her heavy flag
jacket
when she came out of the police station
she was visibly shaken but determined to
continue her work
the case of jivara budari is not
isolated
palestinian journalists complain that
they are systematically harassed
some of them also detained just for
carrying out their jobs
for the hamid al-jazeera in occupied
east jerusalem
adam shapiro is from frontline defenders
he says israeli police have a history of
using this kind of violence against
journalists
what's interesting is that this is
happening against palestinian
journalists
who are part of international media
networks who are covering the protests
in shakeshara
even as there are foreign journalists
there who are not receiving this kind of
treatment so i think
in addition to the message being sent to
journalists generally
and to al jazeera specifically
particularly after al jazeera's offices
were bombed in gaza
there's also a message to palestinian
journalists specifically
about reporting and covering the
palestinian uprising
during the last few weeks it's clear
that there has been a change
in the global media coverage of what's
happening there
as palestinian voices are being given
more space in the media in print and in
other places
and in particular on social media
despite efforts to censor them
uh the israeli government is feeling
pressure in part because of this
and so i think there is kind of a
message being sent by the commanders
in israel to take out journalists to
arrest them to remove them
or in worst case scenario to hit their
buildings or kill them
i think it's important that the at the
not just at the level of the journalists
on the ground but at the level of the
headquarters at the level of the
producers and the
administration of these networks that
they speak out
not only to israeli officials and file
complaints but also to other governments
to western governments
and complain that it's also their
networks it's also their journalists
their employees
who are subject to this kind of violence
and this kind of intimidation and threat
countries that normally promote and
protect freedom above the press